yeah welcome to New 15-minute game and
oh my didn't I play this guy just let's
let me just check yes I had him just a
couple of games ago right I am I am I
wrong here at the time confuse something
mm-hmm I always need to it I had to add
this opening just yes yes I played him
just just a couple of games ago so I
yeah the old Indian again where I
managed to forget to turn on the
recorder and spoke to to nothingness
first okay I I wasted 45 seconds already
for nothing oke for was what I played in
the game before and it was really nice
for what later Bishop g5 as mentioned is
the alternative but I don't know it so
II for and he played g6 and in the game
before let's see him if he decides no
decides to take so need to recapture
very early capture on deform so the
structure is not unusual at all the only
thing is he very early committed to this
pawn structure and add some a point
where the night is already on g7 and
this is actually questionable if you
want to have the night on this heaven so
early sometimes it's useful to to delay
the development of this piece
so how to continue the normal move here
is some SF 3 but it's not not the only
way to continue as majid he took he took
there really early Quincy to look the
one also comes into consideration but
then I always like to protect this
barrack see bind kind of center with f3
yeah c6 blacks ideas to play d5 and I
probably cannot aha so did I lose a
temple there with King King to h1 here
maybe it is very a very normal
preparation with King edge one but i
understand if he go if he is able to
play the 5 line um this is maybe a
rather rather good for black
yeah take twice he will go not to be six
and has very good chance is to to get it
back
yeah the problem at the end he's got
this Bishop on g7 and this is already
good good for black taking twice okay
I'm trying something else I'm trying
Bishop g5 now trying to use them utilize
the better development so yeah after
taking I recapture with the poem this
was at least my intention need to look a
bit yeah yeah need to take with the poem
hmm yeah this is not how I imagined my
position after move 13 maybe King edge
one was a sloppy move I don't know i
mean this position is not not completely
clear no yeah this is this for example i
thought about this and I thought okay
this move is not working because of a
5v5 if he takes with the night be sure
we have six bishop f 6 95 and it's over
yeah I just wind the piece and he five
if he moves to the night I play 95 and
this this is not on I mean cannot do
that so basically if I've looks looks
really good yeah II five night queen bee
to I can also play Knight a form so i
was thinking that this green b6 is not
possible and he went for this strangely
enough i don't know i mean if i was
really an obvious answer I don't know
the position looks looks weird at first
because of this isolated pawn but I've
got everything on active squares nights
on d43 push up on g5 the bishop on e2
always has additional ideas to go to c4
so what Quinn b6 i think was just a
blunder but if he play something else i
am not sure about the position i mean he
is very much behind the development
bishop on see a tall rare still and i
mean i also have the rook developed on
the air foul and so on it looks it looks
quite quite dangerous i think so what
now night to d5 you should take or
Bishop Bishop takes h5 is also i'm
attempting possibility
Bishop takes h 5v I he might play Bishop
takes d5 as add some response
counter-attacking okay let's um look at
95 first what is his reply care queen
bee to giving me even more time Quincy
Pfeifer also head would have night to be
three well what I'm getting at if i get
to d5 p.m. and i'm able to take on h5
and play Knight f6 then this is probably
over to serve this game night here then
you can play Queen takes d5 maybe Bishop
e7 I can take d4f this is not so good i
was thinking like the typical simple who
kind of play i am just attack the Queen
where does it go I don't see a square
only cc6 and I'll see 6 i've got 97 so
where does it go
yeah that's it I just found the Queen
right
yeah no spam Quincy 697 and Cotton's
yeah Queen B 6 was just the lemon cannot
do that please move I think I'm probably
Kim I don't know maybe some some move c5
threatening anyway II 59 takes 94 maybe
it is dangerous already I'm not quite
sure what black should play yeah he
resigned it's really just just the Queen
I'm kind of curious how the computer
assesses this position it gives white a
clear advantage not not overwhelming but
0.7 or something mmm interesting and I
really don't know if this is this is
current theoretical position this kind
of structure is known that it is it is
playable for white I think 26 is just
not on young e 5 and winsome computer
agrees and he obtained the Queen skies
it probably needs to take but tags and
then I would have taken here attending
attending this oh this isn't so great
checks yeah well probably select the
advantage but takes takes you should
reform is the computers objection but
okay dokay what what he wants to do is
stronger I see night to at 5pm okay with
it nights on d5 and f wife this this is
not this is not survivable to black yeah
plus
or something yeah okay thanks for
watching the skin hope you liked it